new video vanessa leaving court late
this afternoon after the verdict jurors
awarded her 16 million dollars in
damages for invasion of privacy here's
how it breaks down 2.5 million for
emotional distress already suffered and
7.5 million for future suffering from
the la fire department she'll receive a
total of 6 million
vanessa's lawyer asked jurors can you
imagine hiking down into a ravine to
take personal souvenir photos of a
deceased child to take them home as a
trophy or souvenir
and we're learning more about anhesha's
final resting place e.t has obtained the
death certificate which indicates anne
was cremated last thursday with her
final place of burial being la's famed
hollywood forever cemetery the 53 year
old actress who died after this horrific
crash will have a spot in one of the
mausoleums close to the actor mickey
rooney ann's 20 year old son homer says
we are convinced our mom would love the
site we have chosen for her it's
beautiful serene and she will be among
her hollywood peers
[Music]